this is the first-ever image of an
actual black hole it's in the center of
a galaxy called m87 55 million light
years away until now we've had our
simulations and hints and cosmological
data but now we can actually see
something and it's a it turns out to be
actually quite beautiful and also sort
of terrifying so to talk about that we
have a couple of Harvard astrophysicists
Michael Johnson and Andrew shale both of
whom worked on that project and they're
gonna talk a little bit more about what
we're seeing the famous thing that
people say about black holes the
gravitational field so powerful that not
even light can escape but of course
we're seeing something around it some
stuff does come out so what comes out
what actually does come out of a black
hole and then what what are we seeing we
see this orange sort of Nimbus what what
can you tell from that what are we
looking at exactly nothing comes out
from inside the event right the boundary
they probably think what we're seeing is
actually light that was captured on a
circular orbit around the black pool and
then flung off that's at the point where
the gravitational field is so strong
that it's making the orbit if the
photons venture a little bit too far
inside of that orbit they'll fall in
once it once it passed the event horizon
nothing but they're things that are sort
of at the edge once it crosses the event
horizon the material is gone but as
stuffs coming in it's getting more and
more compressed and heated and there's
there's viscosity from magnetic fields
that are shearing apart and tearing so
it's heating everything up and all of
the emission is getting amplified just
before it crosses that event price you
know all of this material is getting hot
emitting most of its most of its energy
once it gets close to the black hole and
at that point the black hole takes over
and is warming it into this distinctive
shape so not only is it an incredible
distance away but the image that we're
seeing is also for all intense purposes
50 million years old right like we're
we're pretty far behind here in a way I
mean he summons a very popular target
for astronomers right all astronomers
looking at that maybe seven are looking
at the same 50 million year old light
right the big difference for us is that
to see this mass of stars big ball of
light and if you look carefully you see
a little jet reading off the side we
zoom in on this image Hubble sees zoom
in by another factor of one or two
thousand
that gets us down in the very heart of
this entire region so it's all a game
about how outlying those details you see
and so what did it take to actually see
it what do you have to do to look that
far away how far is it
what kind of telescopes do you use so
it's about 50 million light years away
because of that it's basically so small
that we can't look at it with the normal
telescope we basically stitched together
telescopes from from all over the world
South Pole to Chile to Hawaii to Spain
and record the data there visually and
then go take that data back and sort of
reconstruct an underlying image the data
but that's not a very forward process
because they're only sampling
effectively a mirror this is the earth
in a few locations and from that data
set we have to recover the edge that's
Alan I know you haven't had a lot of
time with it yet but but looking at it
does it as a conform to theory is there
something that you've learned about
black holes that was surprising about it
does it just say like yes we still
understand physics what what does the
image tell you so I mean to me we've
known that there are these intense
concentrations of mass at the Centers of
galaxies but I didn't expect for a
moment that we really would turn on a
telescope and see this ring of light
surrounding a seven billion solar mass
black hole I mean I expected some messy
astrophysical jets you know but instead
you know we see this elemental booming
signal it's really just jaw-dropping
so so in that sense I do think it's a
confirmation of this theory but but it
is you know even in its confirmation I
find it to be quite surprising the
signal of the of the bright ring is
universal that it comes directly from
gravity and you can do a lot of
different things but the physics around
the black hole you can beat the
particles in different ways you can make
it look more or less dense that you
always get this ring so I think a lot
was coming in the future will be what
signals can we now use beyond just ring
in the image I may be polarization maybe
time variability of the events we look
at it from week week or year to year do
you really get at those a physical
questions if it will
possible to look at this with the naked
eye if it were possible to fly a ship
closer to it what would it be like to be
there our images make it look like it's
the sleeping giant
but it's not right this thing is
tremendously dynamical it's like the
surface of the Sun it's boiling and
erupting and and I think that would just
be a tremendously exciting environment
I mean e7 is a supermassive black hole
with 7 billion times much mass as the
Sun and these are these are sort of
gentle monsters where you can you can
creep up to the event horizon and it's
actually it won't tear you apart like it
would for a stellar mass black hole you
cross the event horizon and and if you
would might not even feel it
if you wanted to park a spaceship
outside the event horizon it you would
feel a lot of gravity from the black
hole you'd feel it weigh about 200 times
as much as you do on the earth but you
know that's not so crazy that you're
sitting out this outside this incredible
black hole but at the same time you
would see you'd see this erupting ball
of fire as in this terrifically
dynamical system analogous to say the
surface of the Sun so it'd be really
beautiful to behold there's another
black hole closer to us it's called
saggy starts in the center of our own
galaxy the Milky Way but just because
it's closer
doesn't mean it's easier to see do we
get a chance to look at the one at the
center of our own galaxy at some point
those edge a star and the center of our
galaxy is is a much better source even
for a lot of reasons we have a lot more
detailed probes like we can see
individual stars going around it and we
know it's mass and distance much more
accurately than m87 the difficulty is a
day in the life of m87 is a minute in
electro sad a star and so we see these
hints of variability in m87 over a week
and that means that procedures are we're
expecting to see all sorts of dynamical
activity over you know minute it just
makes it a much more difficult problem
to turn that into a single picture
Michael Johnson and Rochelle thank you
so much for doing this really
appreciating graduations again it's an
amazing result